why track is a new technology that
performs 3d motion tracking of a person
purely using radio reflections of her
body even if the person is moving behind
the wall or furniture white rag is
placed behind the wall of this room as
indicated by the red arrow as the person
walks around in the room it tracks his
motion through the wall in the adjacent
room white rack outputs the location of
the person as a red dot on the screen as
the person moves around behind the wall
there a dot moves on the screen
indicating his exact location at any
point in time so let us see how white
rack works
white rack performs 3d motion tracking
using body radio reflections it
transmits wireless signals whose power
is a hundred times less than Wi-Fi and a
thousand times smaller than cell phone
transmissions these signals were reflect
of the person and come back to its
receive antennas after some delay white
rack measures the delays and math some -
the distance travelled by the signals
based on a geometric model of the
antennas white I can now accurately
determine the location of the person the
model incorporates new algorithms that
remove reflections due to walls and
furniture and focus only on the
reflections of a human body even if the
person is behind a wall or in a
completely different room in this demo
the person walks unexpired on the ground
as the red dog tracks him in the bottom
left corner of the screen now that the
spiral on the ground is only there to
show the accuracy of the system and is
not used to aid localization in any way
the system has a large number of
applications for example it performs
highly accurate localization simply
using reflections of a person's body
without requiring the person to hold any
device it can also be used in gaming
where it can start players as they run
down hallways or hide behind furniture
and walls from videogame enemies the
system not only tracks the location of a
person but can also track his body parts
in this example the person is
controlling different household
appliances turning them on and off by
simply pointing his hand in their
direction because why track works
through walls it can allow you to
control appliances even from another
room say you leave a room and forget to
turn off the lights
all you have to do is point your hand in
the direction of that room to turn the
lights off why track therefore can
perform 3d motion tracking of humans and
body parts simply using radio
reflections of a person's body and it
works even through walls and
obstructions